Renee Brown is the New York Times
bestselling author and researcher behind
the most one of the most popular TED
talks in history the power of
vulnerability has been viewed more than
46 million times
she's also released a Netflix special
and was profiled last night on 60
minutes now she's out with a new podcast
unlocking us about why being new at
anything is hard
Brene brown joins us from Houston good
morning welcome Brene good morning thank
you for having me on
the theme of your first episode is about
navigating these first times and boy are
we all dealing with a lot of them first
time I'm broadcasting from home but you
actually you believe this these are kind
of critical learning moments for all of
us
why is what's your advice for dealing
with it I mean I personally I'm not
comfortable like everyone else with
first times but I think they're
incredibly important because we get to a
place especially as adults where we stop
doing anything that we're not already
good at and that discomfort and
vulnerability and awkwardness of being
new is really the juice it's the
lifeblood for us and the more new things
we lean into the more new things we're
willing to try and that's that's growth
for us and when we shut that down we
stop living we stop growing and so
unfortunately we were all collectively
hurled into this first time but there
are things we can do to make first times
which are often pretty terrible better I
feel emotionally drained
I feel spiritually drained I think a lot
of people are feeling this during this
time and you say when you name the hard
things it gives you power what do you
mean by that cuz I don't feel a lot of
people feel that they're that they are
powerful at this particular time or even
feeling they're in power yeah I think
you know my favorite definition of power
is from Martin Luther King jr. he said
power is the ability to affect change
that simply
what I what I mean by owning it is when
we're in grief which I think we're all
in collective grief right now when we're
in grief when we're in fear and anxiety
a lot of us have this myth that if I
name it and if I say that out loud
it gives that hard feeling power when
the truth is it gives us power because
we put a handle on what we're feeling
and so I do think most of us feel very
powerless right now around COBIT
especially but to be able to name what
we're feeling helps us move through it
and helps us say okay this is normal I
mean we are we are both trying to grieve
the loss of normal and also at the exact
same time find our footing in a new
normal and that's a big ask of us
individually and collectively
hey hey Brunei there's a great moment in
the Amy Poehler movie wine country where
you play yourself and some people come
to your table at a restaurant and you
lecture them on boundaries you draw the
boundaries like this with all these
people working from home and dealing
with family boundaries how do they go
about gently drawing the line and saying
hey this is my space in my time you know
I gotta tell you like and for me and my
family it's my 20 year old who's you
know used to living by herself off at
college that has been she showed me the
way this time because she sat down and
said you know here's what's okay and
here's what's not okay and so I think
checking in yeah I know you love you
you're happy to have me home but you
know here's what works for me right now
and so and we are all just asking each
other you know here's what's working and
here's what's not working but the minute
you shut down the communication about
what you need resentment is a really
festering thing when you're sharing
space involuntarily with a lot of people
so I think asking for a thank you
is great alright burn a brown thank you
so much for being with us unlocking us
is available on podcast platforms